yeah I mean
I like to think of myself as an honest
guy like there's one rule I'm almost too
truthful like my girlfriend's sitting
off camera and she would agree that I
I almost almost say the truth too much
because that's that's just the rules I
live by so
I would much rather just know the body
count and make a decision from there I
have certain standards it's none of your
business though but you know it doesn't
matter it does matter though yeah it
does make your business it is
it is yes it is it is because it shows
to me
like a sense of self-value
um I think especially from a female like
from a male perspective like when you
meet a meet a girl
it shows to me a sense of self-value
because
I think everyone could agree here that
most guys
can sleep with someone and it could mean
nothing whereas with girls not every
time okay there's exceptions to the rule
but I think a lot of times it takes a
lot to get into that into that place
and
what are you getting from it like so why
are you shaking your head I know girls
that sleep with guys just because they
want to have sex yeah yeah same like a
guy can do it let me do it they're at
that point where I'm a hoe I've done it
yeah men and women are different and
understanding and so men have to have
women have a certain level of
requirements to sleep with a man because
some people say oh women have sex and
because it takes a lot more for women to
have sex but I've literally seen girls
that will sleep with men and feel no
time yeah but they don't they don't
start like that they do they don't they
don't know typically they're they're not
typically they don't kill us they don't
typically start they they become that
but when they're 15 16 17 18 whenever
they lose their virginity they're not
they don't they're all born a Savage
they're made because they've just been
and that's and that's why men don't want
girls that are ran through because you
you can't connect as much the more
people you slept with uh but I grew up
seeing girls sleeping around I've seen
it yeah so I saw it in that Community
that's why I can speak and growing up I
saw a lot of girls and it was kind of
like you had you had girls who were
known for giving head you had this girl
known for this like in different areas
there's a bunch of hoes like a lot a lot
a lot a lot so every time things have
changed things have Society has actually
changed
why isn't it why isn't it a man's
business to know your past because your
past dictates your future if you if you
have if you have it does if you have
habits your habits are who you are so if
you spend if you spent five years
sleeping around let's just say then how
how is he to know that you won't do that
again when you turn 32 like like because
you have that past like I'll give you an
example I used to drink okay in college
I drank and I decided to stop drinking I
don't drink anymore and the thing is
there's always a part of me that's going
to want to drink because I did it I
started it I used to really like it and
so it's like if you used to be a hoe
there's a part of you that's going to
want to go back no matter how much you
suppress it okay because you used to do
it a guy then as well a guy yeah I think
your habits like if a guy's sleeping
with everybody is it going to be hard
for him to stop yes but the thing is men
and women are different we value
different things girls don't care as
much if they get cheated on as as women
do they don't I'm sorry it's not the
same because then we wouldn't pick the
guys that cheat like I'm sorry we go for
the guys we go 100 of women want 20 of
men so if we're picking the guys that
are going to cheat there's there's one
out of three men that are virgins so go
pick them if you want to be a guy that's
faithful you are what you do yeah but
the thing is though to be honest I've
never heard well from friends and stuff
and our culture in UK is different
people don't really have a culture that
a guy would even leave you based on how
many people you've slept with do they
really care no no what age they do they
know this is our age they cared a lot so
they do care and one thing I noticed you
see with this whole body kind of thing
yeah girls like they literally their
body parts
they may lie what's your bank account
statement then the thing is though that
was never again honest answer I know
girls that have lied there was like um
I I go to the extremes right I'll take a
polygraph test you take a polygraph test
let's go that's how committed I am like
that is the place and what happens when
the body part is she did you take a
polygraph test
I'll take one you can ask me anything
anything okay I am fully committed what
happens when you hear some think you do
not like what happens and you're already
in love with this girl like you you know
you want to marry her like for me would
that be the determining thing no and you
know that it was her past no no no I see
what you're saying I see what you're
saying for what what I was saying is
when you're in that first
um interaction yeah it depends on the
damage right it does depend on the
damage like if it's so much worse then
it's so much worse
but
I Believe In Truth like and it may be an
optimistic idealistic view of the world
but
I think you should be willing to put all
your cards on the table and I think the
truth comes out eventually Maybe not
today maybe not today maybe not tomorrow
but like if you've been sleeping around
town he's gonna he's gonna run into
someone you slept with exactly so so
like you're right women I I do see hoes
get wifed all the time I I do see it and
a lot of times the men don't know but
the truth comes out or they leave
because they're too damaged are there
some who have been too so okay let me
just say this now there's no win-win
then for her it's Eva you tell the truth
you like the guy will leave you and then
you try going this straight and narrow
you've been literally celibate let's say
five years and that's not your lifestyle
it could also be it could be it could be
to lower your standards and think Hmm
you know I'm not a virgin so maybe I
could date outside of the church and he
doesn't have to be equally yoked because
how yoked am I if I'm not if I'm not a
virgin anymore
they do work they they date outside
and they're going out with
um say ghetto guys they've gone out of
guys who are proper hardcore you know
what I mean don't believe in no church
they believe in Saturday night I'm going
out raving that's what they believe in
so so they'll be in the church and
dating the guy yeah the the but he's not
a husband right
it's just the way you told the story
that's the way no no he wouldn't be
husband material okay but then again
they might want him to be husband
material he might be really good in bed
and you know good in bed might qualify
him to be you know he he might be able
to do to make me happy I've I've just
found that a lot of the women in the
church have too high of Standards
because they aren't what men value
anymore
and so I just I've just found a lot of
like 27 28 29 to 35 year olds that
aren't virgins requiring a man that's
equally yoked and I think that's a tough
ask and I think if we want to build
families like that's going to be tough
that's going to be hard so people can't
change then
you can try they just have to lower
their standards that's that's all as
long as they lower their standards I
think that's fine I think it also women
can do that very well lowering the
standards I think I think if that was
true then fifty percent of women that
hit 30 wouldn't be single and childless
because one again one out of three men
are virgins the men are there that want
to commit so women women
um on dating apps they only swipe right
five percent of the time so that that's
telling me that we don't in fact lower
our standards I think on the body count
thing and so to your point right I think
you have to be realistic you have to
know where you're at and I think
if you come in with a realistic View and
an open conversation you at least
increases the chance of speaking truth
right but I'm not saying it business or
that to me as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible